I want to take a moment right now to
thank the world for standing up with us
in our fight for equality we see you we
thank you we love you I am a man who is
frustrated I'm disappointed I'm angry
you guys stay strong we got this they
say it takes a village this is one hell
of a village that I'm looking at right
now all you looters you need to stop
because you've destroyed too many
people's dreams around the country star
wars actor John boyega gave it an
emotional speech in London that line
inspired several big directors and
writers to tell John they'd be honored
to work with him including Oscar winner
Jordan Peele who wrote we got you John
Henry Goulding wearing all black and
marching with his hands in the air and
Ellen Pompeo took a knee with protesters
in Hollywood but today all eyes on
Minneapolis
George Floyd's memorial was broadcast
live on the major networks and news
channels we are on the street where
Floyd pleaded for his life saying he
could not breathe
[Music]
that is Kevin Hart sitting with Ludacris
in the front row they arrived together
on a bus that also included super
producer will Packer Tiffany Haddish
Kevin and Ludacris Tyler Perry loaned
out his private jet to Reverend Al
Sharpton so he could safely travel to
the memorial amid the pandemic we can't
let this go we can't keep living like
this Tyler also provided plane service
for George Floyd's family members to fly
in from Texas I know him being a strong
person he was and seeing everybody come
together and just rally around him and
they stand out of the love and supports
our family and we thankful and grateful
[Music]